guys happy birthday to justine that's me
i can't believe this so we were just
about ready to start setting up for the
party tonight we're having a mario party
10 party and
the cake is here and i can already see
it and i'm kind of like freaking out
i hope it's okay
holy
holy moly
i can see inside of it i already see it
holy crap it's beautiful
that's the coolest birthday cake i've
ever seen
everything that i ever wanted and that's
your little character this is my me
how do you like it jenna it is the most
perfect thing that i've ever seen in my
entire life we can't eat it oh my gosh
that's because it is the new nintendo ds
color too i made it off the c-stick oh
they forgot the c-sticks
what do we do how do we keep it cool
refrigerate it
yeah so it's occupido i might have
bought a little bit of velcro there's a
lot of
holy moly the friends for the for my
friends okay jen thanks so much for my
cake you're welcome it's probably i
don't even know what to taste like but
it doesn't even matter it doesn't matter
because it looks awesome and these are
all of the new amiibos who are going to
come to the party i'm going to bring
them down so we decided we're going to
set up a photo booth at south by
southwest i went over to like the intel
gaming section and they had a bunch of
microsoft surfaces and i was so excited
because they gave me one to test out for
the week and i couldn't fit my laptop in
my
book bag so they let me use this at
south by and it was honestly a life
saver and guess what else it's gonna be
at this current party photo booth we
tested it yesterday you're not gonna
like it fits perfectly like it's almost
as if it's made for it this was made
for you and maybe for the birthday party
look at this
this is the photo booth even have a
lighting kit yep wow okay we can put the
timer on
oh it's great it's great everyone has
really cute little noises i was a
surprise when i first got it because it
actually takes really good video to the
front facing watch we're gonna do a
video now oh oh
this is this is amazing
i can't believe it i think i'm gonna
permanently leave it here you should i
think it's a great idea everyone that
comes in has to do a little photo booth
session i wonder if there's an app like
a phone number like a digital like guest
but super cool it's really cool i think
you actually built that shelf for
the surface i did it
the surface
this the surface was built for the shelf
cool i can't wait to party all right jen
guess what we need to do now for we
gotta add some more decorations look at
this amazing birthday present this isn't
such an amazing birthday all my friends
here well they're not all here yet but
adam came into town doesn't even live
here flew in for the party like i
wouldn't miss it though of real life
mario party it's amazing so i'm glad i
saved these for my last party can you
even like when people say what yep when
people say literally can't even like
this is what they mean where do we put
them everywhere everywhere party is now
starting to kick off
tiffany brought some mario accessories
oh
lollipops francesca bought emojis and
then drew shows up with the hat already
on oh andy brought oh wait show them
what you brought show them
are you this is amazing yes with the
classic super mario world and super
mario kart classic really really great
i can't even believe it we don't we're
not eating it we can't eat it
21 years old today that's me look at
that happy birthday to me you look so
good thank you thank you it's funny
because i think i was 21 last year too
it's crazy how that happens
guys we're gonna cut the cake
mario party is really really really
intense but we're gonna cut the cake you
guys ready yeah okay okay i'm so nervous
i'm gonna i'll put record
i'm gonna record the video
on the surface
we're gonna cut it
out you cut it
today i'm 21. happy birthday
is this even my camera i think it's
yours happy birthday to
you
happy birthday to
happy birthday
happy birthday to you
make a wish and there's no
where's the knife oh my god it's so cute
you didn't see the case that's on the
instagram i just said
the lights
it's all right you know
it's something unfollow
me
with two hands please
i'm cutting your birthday cake should i
do it okay
yeah right down the d yes
i feel like this is like a wedding we're
like filming her cutting it should
probably save a slice of it and put it
in the freezer
great celebrate next year
oh
oh my god chuck burke is here the
strippers are here
i think what are you doing
that was you i've do it it wasn't you
somebody grabbed my body
there's your piece joey
i know right
that's like i put this in like eight
pieces hmm
just a little bit of a mess
i don't like it
i got a lot of street passes last night
good straight people we got 10 street
people
so one of the requirements of coming to
justine's birthday party was bringing
your ds so that we could share street
passes it's true and i met you i think
for the fifth or sixth time i love it we
should be more exciting so it's the day
day after my birthday and jenna's here
hanging out hello you missed the fun
cleanup oh my goodness it was a hot mess
yeah sorry i couldn't be there for that
it's okay adam helps me adam is so sweet
i love adam i love i love adam so much
um so i was just about to
i wanted to look through some of the
pictures that we took i think i might be
obsessed with the microsoft surface i
just like it's like basically a freaking
computer but it's like a tablet i want
to see that some of our video actually
oh my god
me and ed we got our camos
i had a really fun time
oh my god oh that's funny oh joey hey
hey joey
i didn't even know this is all going on
i'm just walking around in the
background
it's true
oh my god
both sides the front and the back it's
1080p which is
pretty that was actually really funny i
know
happy birthday to you
i didn't even know anybody even
made any movies this is great oh my god
this is awesome this video is actually
really good oh it's our little group
picture that was hard it was actually
very hard and i think lamar's right
there
he is in there you just can't quite see
him i think someone was right here too
santino did not want to be in the video
i did not want to be well thank you for
everyone for coming to my party oh my
gosh
i don't even know what's happening
this thing's amazing that's great
which is really great
just testing
i think i'm making a video this is my
first video
hello
oh my god i love it well thank you guys
so much for all of your birthday tweets
and and everything it was really it was
quite an overwhelming day everyone was
so sweet and so awesome i love you guys
i'll see you in my next video thanks for
my amazing cake jeff you're welcome i
didn't make it so it was
it doesn't matter is it a problem oh my
goodness and then i have like analog
photos
brie thank you brie for the amazing
present that you didn't even know that
you got me what you did but because
jenna picked it out i got one of those
little um little like it's not polaroid
things fuji fuji fiji i don't know
whatever but they're really cute and we
just got a little
book to put the photos in
focus you pig
you get the point you get the point
i'm gonna go bye